modern
iido couple things that Mark it one it's
very linear very
two-dimensional what we want
is
more I say the spiraling rotating
cross so you got to take this
shape and it has to start
spinning on at least two planes
but then that
spinning
cross has to now
travel on a spiral across the sagittal
plane this is where where that x pattern
comes
in so as I draw like a cork screw roller
coaster you have to imagine that shape
on the
trajectory of the Spiral that I just
drew but it
is doing this
itself okay so it's going through space
doing the
spinning as it's doing
that a linear line is cut
across an inertial
line that is never traced I never trace
it it's an it's an inertial line that
happens through the middle we're going
this way on the sagittal plane while
we're
spinning spinning and spiral
rotating so I'll establish an inertial
line and across the inertial
line I draw or I do through
EDI
uh
another Vector of
force Mii and that's the x
pattern as we've said many times that
sends the top and bottom of the person's
posture usually the head and and the
feet in opposite directions from the
center or the top of the line of
gravity in a third Direction now there
is no chance that they can remain
standing you've done a throw throw or a
pin okay that's what we try to
do that makes the ukemi extremely
difficult
especially for modern
aikidoka who are only used to this two
dimensional iido and I'll explain
that the first reason why it makes it
extremely difficult is that the UK
finally
experiences a total lack of control of
their body mass and so it may be for the
first time in their lives that they're
actually thrown
that generates a huge amount of fear
because one of our greatest fears is the
loss of
control we always want to know what
we're doing why we're doing it where
it's going to lead us
to we want to know the
weather we want to know what the future
is I want to understand if this worth it
or not all these kind of things our
entirety of our life is built
around the illusion of control because
the egoic mind is seeking power
over the
most difficult aspect of God which is
Thou shalt not
know and for that reason in your modern
UK who's just doing
exercise just can't take this ukemi
okay you add to that the fact that we're
often not training that much so we're
not that strong or we're not that Supple
we're not that mobile and just we don't
have the physicality for that kind of
throw in any way that we can endure
endure it over
a long duration of time with multiple
consecutive reps it's very
difficult
inversely what iido does instead let's
just stick with the forward roll is they
simply
accelerate the
UK the UK is running this way they will
UK the UK bodies
here it is brought
forward and then lowered the head the
head is lowered in some fashion such
that this shape ends up in this shape
okay the UK then under this shape
ceases to try to put their feet back
underneath their head and thereby
reigning their line of gravity under or
within their base of support so they
don't have to
fall several things do
this one
choreography if I tilt and lower your
head that's your cue to do a forward
roll you pay attention something else
happens at the higher
levels is the UK will always leave their
feet
there and more
importantly will often put their feet
there I'll try to find videos where you
see very very high highly skilled UK in
the modern sense of the word with very
highly ranked n and the UK will put
their foot back there to generate this
angle
this is exactly the opposite of what a
person who does not want to be thrown
will do a person who does not want to be
thrown when leaned will always put their
feet back underneath their line of
gravity and this is one reason
why iido trades the illusion of control
for the sake of that egoic
fear and in doing so so they can't
address a marshal context because the
Marshal context is marked by its
unknowability
just won't
function what I say to do is you got to
get off of this idea that I accelerate
my UK and that they're going to do a
forward roll one you're just practicing
the fear and
control which is just going to lead to a
separation from
God and an idolatry of self and the
greatest sin you replace yourself with
God because you're going to
know you cannot
know
however as you will probably not have UK
that can do the EXP
pattern you have to at least be aware
of when you're no longer throwing for
what I say at throwing from control I am
in control of the ukas
body you are now throwing from
transaction which
means if they do a forward
roll and I'm doing this
acceleration not the x
pattern they did the forward roll
because they entered into transaction
with me
I won't exp pattern your
ass I'll accelerate your
ass and you will participate in it by
leaving your feet there okay some people
need to train at that level the
uncommitted the old the out of
shape the ones who can't get over any
semblance of fear and just train there
okay so I don't know where your ukah are
but you have to keep that in mind
okay I'm going to show you the
technique um from the point of view of
the x pattern right now you're doing the
acceleration throw okay I want to throw
from control not from
transaction certain things have to be
done
differently in order to make that other
shape
happen and to have that X itself
spinning on it
to establish that inertial line that I'm
eventually going to cut through
dimashi some third Force line through
there so that these three things that
make up posture the two distal ends and
the center Go in different directions
okay uh we'll focus in on just a couple
uh one is going to we'll do the hand
work and then I'll show you where the
adashi is um and you'll see that the
it's going to come back to this overall
strategy am I simply accelerating UK or
am I doing the next pattern and throwing
from control versus transaction okay
that's where we'll go now so we have uh
CL
please we have lots of videos on on this
technique so I'm not going to show
everything a bunch of detail again I
want to just focus on the hand workk and
how to throw from control okay uh
but this is a counter rotation so
normally we would come in something like
this okay and do whatever so he's going
around that way and I go around that way
okay this one is a counter rotation
where I'm going the opposite way of him
okay I don't turn where he's
turning um and it's important to note
that because that counter ation for
example going back to the video with
Ronin where I first showed what is a
marshall application of iido is as I
start spiral rotating the fight and he
tries to cut me off then I'll counter
rotate and do that a lot okay and really
that's where this shows up if you don't
rotate the fight you'll never see Tenon
and you'll never see counter rotation is
absolutely never going to show up in
your Marshall situation okay so for
example you'll have a lot of boxers and
they never counter rotate or I'm sorry
they never counter rotate because they
never rotate you'll have those fighters
who will rotate and you will see Tenon
in boxing this people don't recognize it
but it is in there okay they're counter
rotating when you see that kind of stuff
okay so uh that's why it makes no sense
that
um this kind of stuff y around you see
and I'm here and he walks around me and
then I
throw I have to start a counter
rotation so the the counter rotation is
I'm going this way and then he came
around and I came the other way that has
to be in there okay resist the
temptation that I'm here and goes here
and then I accelerate
back um another quick thing
here is it is a legitimate
attack it is a legitimate attack see uh
to get the arm and you have this throw
here it it's very very
powerful when done full speed you don't
need anything fancy just grab the wrist
and pull them
backwards um there's only been one time
where I threw roning onto his head and
it's on that technique and if you want
to see it it's in one of the manual
compilations we have two of those videos
I don't know which one but it's the one
time I've freaking dropped them on his
head okay it's extremely
powerful um and it's a good one for your
bag of tricks where you don't need
anything fancy okay and that's what's
kind of going on here sort of okay all
right so we also know the third thing
that we only have two
handshakes that's all I have um I don't
have this one
I never have this one okay uh I don't
have this one either a lot of people in
the Federation will understand like if I
leave my skeletal alignment then I feel
very strong you see very strong when I
do that so you'll see people will will
do that kind of stuff B strong never
give him a
Advantage okay or they'll seek a lot of
even uh he grabs right and you go they
do this kind of stuff you see so he's
really olding me and they'll move their
Center you see and they hit these very
small elbows but the fight stops so it's
just okay um and because it's
just a leverage technique someone's
strong enough you're not going to get
the leverage it's just not going to
happen Okay and those aren't our shapes
we can't use those shapes they don't do
anything for my energetics
um and so they don't do anything for my
deconstruction of the egoic mind so when
he comes
around you have to
find is
she because we don't film the teacher
back you have to
find the inward
spiral okay he comes in and I'm
doing okay but I have to do it
in a way that I'm not contesting his
energy so as his energy goes
down I can turn to keep that
neutral okay we'll do it again you know
we're going to turn this way camera stay
there one I move keep it neutral okay do
it one more
time so I have to rotate
and that starts the counter rotation
okay and then here is that opening that
you would use the counter rotation for
stay there please just move your arm out
of the way here's where you move to do
all those kind of manles
okay
so don't come back in the diagonal
there's no rotation there and you can
see I'm not on that angle
my body rotates and there's that angle
right there okay do the other side body
rotate that's the angle I want I'm just
looking at this part here and the foot
work so because I rotate I can counter
rotate rotate and I can counter
rotate rotate I can counter rotate
boom boom now watch my hips and you'll
see what I mean hips turn hips
turn hips turn hips
turn turn turn okay so I'll get how do
we get the arm over I was doing it but
not all the way okay let's try
that all right so my and this hand
here is going to go into the inward
spiral and then I turn as it's
continuing its inward
spiral so my hand doesn't
go
back up right here this is the outer
deltoid and I can't lift him okay but
you always see that in Ikea because
people go like that okay but he's way
stronger than me so my hand can't go
like this it's like no way cannot do it
okay this spiral
turns W turns and as it turns I move
into the in space
let's look at some of the things it does
different on his arm so even if I was
strong enough his wrist elbow and
shoulder are in alignment
okay we'll do it one more time I don't
know if the camera caught that okay so
we're here even though I was strong
enough we're in alignment and then if I
was strong
enough there we go okay watch his
wrist will slow down so you can see
comes around I'm already getting his
elbow out of that alignment you see so
here for example if I don't move there's
your assum a TOS right
there
Bo boom and now what I'm doing is
throwing the
elbow
over on the other one if I was strong
I'm
pulling and then they accelerate
themselves
here I'm throwing that elbow over okay
uh trade
camera this also makes the elbow so when
I'm here like this she's shorter than me
and when I have my arm straight here and
I bring this up I got to bring this way
up there do you see and a lot of people
let go there when they're
shorter but what I'm going to do is
bring her elbow up you see her elbow's
coming up and that gives me my opening
to back
out this way and because I'm throwing
her I can pick her up over that I pick
her up not them reaching up over me okay
of course you have to adopt you can just
change your height there going to be a
ceiling in other words to how much you
can get away with but having the elbow
up here as opposed to the arm out you
got to go way high to get that elbow
higher than your head okay um the
ceiling is much lower as you're doing it
that way okay so we're now add that to
It
Go yep
no no need to extend your arm just keep
the elbow where it is turn
better okay so he's lifting it up which
is the most common
thing okay so you moved your spiral
ahead of your body your body turns the
spiral
turns so that same thing there so your
elbow Gets behind
you
better again keep going we'll keep going
till we get
it better there you go
better that's
it a lot of people because they have
just leverage system or uh which is or
if it's inferior to the UK um they will
never give them anything as I mentioned
earlier okay so they come around like
this and they stay in front then he
grabs my arm out there okay now the
technique doesn't make any sense because
um
he's attacking my wrist and not me okay
so you don't do that you have to bait
him on the other the hand you have to
bait him and then you do the same in
spiral okay to get control of it so I'm
going to take the footwork out just
enough but you bait him and
those are
this not this
not that
either two
[Music]
spirals if we now look at the first one
again slow down please on the first one
you get the
sumoto here and that's what you're going
to find here
too boom it's right there
show me your tush show me
[Music]
your
different out in front
different sort of it but
not okay
timing okay let's try we're going to
look at the second
spiral not the firstand this
one yes you have to not start spiral so
you can spiral
him give him that hand spiral that hand
so not quite don't turn your wrist it's
just like you de me
nugget you went over the head that
time keep
going don't lift up over your
head turn the spiral that's better and
then we prematurely spiral the other
hand let him touch
it so prematurely spiral so I'll show
you what I
mean oh this is my final position but I
don't I don't just have it so I don't go
here and
here and as you watch you see I'm
outward spiral he cuts down inward
spiral we going to watch the second hand
now on that same thing so I'm in the
outward spiral position which means the
elbow is in you see and now that he
grabs it that's when I take it and find
the Su t on the
elbow what you're doing is you're coming
here and he doing it to him
okay so I
blend
[Music]
boom boom turns with him boom turns with
him you want him to grab it OB in
him okay try it a little
more got to you you got to spiral him on
that second arm
no it's already spiraled keep
going you're lifting that hand
up okay so I be coming
in guard your
face okay and then I take this Ro see
and I'm going to pull your Center back
you feel it
boom there's the
throw okay it we go
slow there was a downward energy
clearly okay so I come
around there's that energy there you see
pick your arm
up see you can't pick it
up what you have to do instead is turn
it
go
back watch this now okay you know there
was a downward right you feel it right
there and watch as I take the next step
stay still as I take the next step
you're going to feel more downward you
see there's more downward right and
that's where everyone tries to live
which is crazy okay now watch put your
other foot forward now watch the next
thing there's also an inwardness
to this energy it's going down right
it's going in too you see that okay and
as I take that next step it goes in too
you see that it won't come out until I
take my
T on that inward
energy is where you pass it okay so I'm
going to help you put your hand up guard
your face
okay don't fight it don't try to take me
yet wait for the inward energy there it
is now it goes around you see that and
you go don't don't overbend your
elbow stay there
please this is what your picture
see and don't throw me like this you see
that don't overbend your
elbow
okay we're just here
when you feel
that that's what you want you take it
around you you go under it that's what
you
do
okay it's not going to get
up take it I'm going to go
down and I'm going in that's where you
take it around you better now we'll do
this second hand let's stick on that
side
please the second
hand let me get
it you see it's it feels like it's on
your back to you but not if you do the
inward
spirals if you try to extend
it yes it's on your back okay but you're
going to turn because that's what that
hand is doing don't overbend That Elbow
do you see that and now it's not on your
back got it so go
back bait me I would be here and as you
feel me you would feel that
push and that's what you want more
action here though you're just doing
this okay the elbow and the wrist travel
around each other not like this look at
my
elbow look at my my
thumb okay not like this okay all right
try some more all right we want to look
more closely at the two
sues
okay so
this
wrist is here not here it's here you
take the slack
out and then when you take the slack out
now the elbow
it's going to articulate less another
reason why you don't go like
this you're going to take the slack out
of the wrist and now you're going to
drive the
Palm which drives the elbow and you do
that with the two hands so we go really
slow
Bo same thing on the St same thing on
the bottom hand Bo
you have to get the wrist to run out of
its
articulation boom okay Z best you can so
now you're throwing that elbow down and
this
elbow this way like
eal and this one like actual Sun tush
okay uh this one is going to be a like
there's a Force there through the wrist
and this one like there's a force on the
inside there like
that that's what you want to feel his
Center
through okay so we're going to just do
that hand
work
Bo and then leave the me off see the X
pow out what
it's very
different where I've been where I just
accelerate now okay so I'm trying to not
do my footwork on
here full drive that
down the elbows
you should end up here and not here with
your palm wrist forget my stance not
here not
here okay let's try no
no try it
again so get his wrist to bend by doing
so you're extending your hands the way
down towards the ground okay cuz you
smell the leverage but you don't want to
do that you want his wrist to throw his
elbows so you you want to go down like
that okay so I I know I can't throw you
but let me at least let you feel what
I'm talking about okay we'll just do one
hand okay one hand all right so when I
come like
this I don't want to go here
see feel it in your fingers you see that
so lift up so you feel the counter
energy you see that's a way of doing it
got it okay I don't want to turn you
here and spear through your
grips this way you see so lift up so you
feel that that's not what I'm doing
either okay what I'm going to do is
turn your wrist do you see that okay
okay and I keep turning until so what
I'm doing is
this do you see come back cuz you
countered
it okay I'm doing lifting here you see
that I'm not trying to do it ended up
happening there I'm lifting this hand
like that okay so when you're there
okay I got to do that i t in the wrist
that gets your elbow okay so here we go
you see what I mean
one
fingers spear through your
grip just you holding on this one light
boom bo this way okay
right okay so going to set up the E me
okay so we know that there's energy
going
here and if we watch his final
attack there
see see he's opening is right
here
so you got to not make the
mistake that you're trying to do do like
a Ura version where you're coming to the
back because we're not we're in the
front we're going to attack the front
we're going to do a m okay so as he
comes around you have to watch your
because you missed it you
see you want him to end boom right
there okay so what am I doing I I took
the arms out a little bit but we'll just
get to that last Point
okay you're doing that's where the x is
okay so you have two
possibilities
um which gives you your spectrum for the
Emi one I can take out the dominant leg
or two I can project this leg okay
okay um
into that angle
there usually when you go fast that's
that that's the leg you hit you can't
hit the front leg but when you go slow
you can hit the front leg okay so as
he's coming around I'm timing
it okay so we'll come up roll your your
up a little bit
and uh he's in that last stance and here
here's what I'm doing I'm going so
there's no no arm movement you could
even be up a little okay okay I'm going
through
here
okay now you add the arm movement you
have this do you see that's all I need
okay okay and so he's there you can hold
on to me with the other hand if you want
he's there with the elbows going down
and his base is going out the other way
that's what you're doing
okay Bo there it is right there
couple
couple things you'll notice
here he's not way out in front of me and
I'm not on the side of
him you're going to
see that as this hand does the spiral
his head comes in you
see this hand helps his head come
in that's what generates very much like
any other of our x pattern throws so
here's kiten nag which we showed
recently his head comes
in
and on the same line that I'm entering
on today with my actual feet
okay so home I throw his elbows take his
face
his facee
out let him come there
it's very Compact and
tight
okay okay all right try
it so over out you want went too far out
far
out you're backing out too far this this
technique all what I said before was to
show you the concepts but then I gave
you you can't back all that way out
because we're not doing Ura okay you
have to time all your hand work so that
he lands on that OT hip okay
[Music]
a little
better better there you go
better okay and you can see she doesn't
have to overextend we're not really
accelerating him you go fast the throws
over
instantaneously okay